- Gurgle…gurgle?
- Gurgle, gurgle. Gurgle, gurgle.
- My whole team is out, and we’re forced to start guys from the Baltimore Orioles.
- Please! We can barely play baseball.
- We need you to play spoiler.
- Good thing this year the Delaware Clams are unlimited.
- What?
- What does that mean?
- Like breadsticks?
- As coach of the Clams, I know it may take us a decade to be ready—
- Next!
- LET’S TRY EVEN THOUGH IT DOESN’T MATTER!
- WOOO!
- YEAH!
- Everyone! Stop getting distracted by Davis Mills!
First up: Spoil the Dolphins.
- I’m so proud of us. We’re finally a team—
- Hi, Miami, it’s little ol' Russell Wilson. Perhaps you could trade for me?
- HELL YEAH.
- Then we take on the Colts.
- All right, men, it's easy. We beat the Jags, and we're in the playoffs. Sleep well.
- [Whispering:] Carson, do something wacky.
- I've had a vision!
- Then we finish off the Browns.
Huh, guess the Browns took care of themselves.
Hey, how are the fans in New York?
- Don't come. They're so mean.
- Then we celebrate with a photo—
- [Voice alarm:] HEADQUARTERS BREACHED, PREPARE TO CLAM UP.
- Give me one good reason why I shouldn’t bite off every one of your f--king heads.
- This truce won’t last forever, Teamy. I will end you.
- ONLY I GET TO KILL YOU, YA HEAR?
MARK MY WORDS: THE ONLY THING THE WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM WILL BE RENAMED
IS THE DELAWARE F--KING CLAMS.